Now I confess, I've been oversimplifying it because we haven't talked about friction.
Now even though energy can never ever be created or destroyed,
friction in a way removes energy from a system.
Now what do I mean by that. Well before we ??? let's say a ball dropping from some height.
Well, we can think of this as energy converting from gravitational potential
to a kinetic energy as it moved in.
All of the gravitational I want to connect, but in reality that's not what happens.
All of the gravitational potential energy does not get convert to kinetic energy.
How did friction do this? How does it remove energy if energy can't be created or destroyed?
Well before when we look at, let's say a block sliding down a plane.
We visualized this as gravitational potential energy
getting converted to kinetic energy as the block moved down, but let's think about that.
As this blocks slides down, it's rubbing against this plane.
Go ahead and rub your hands together for a second and do it really hard.
They get really hot. In fact, friction creates heat. This heat is another form of energy.
If we start with a certain amount of gravitational potential energy,
some of it gets converted to useful kinetic energy, but some gets lost as heat.
The energy is still there, it's just that we can't really use it anymore. It's lost as heat to the atmosphere.
Now depending on the material of this plane or other situational factors, the fraction of this energy
that gets converted to heat can change,
maybe a lot of this energy gets converted to heat maybe almost none of it.
So let's consider these three cases.
In the first case, we have an object falling and let's say it's falling to what's called vacuum
so there's no air, it's just falling through empty space
Another example of object sliding down this rough jagged surface.
Another we have an object sliding down a relatively smooth surface.
What I want to know is, which of this diagrams corresponds to which of this pictures.
So in this diagram all of the potential energy is getting converted to kinetic energy
and here most of it is getting converted to heat, but in here only a small portion gets converted to heat.
Enter the appropriate number into the appropriate box.